hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John we are going to watch from a
channel up top screen so this is a
tribute to Mark Ruffalo yeah can we
check this out one of our topper wore
tears over on our patreon page which is
currently full so don't try to pledging
right now we're video requesting was
definitely doing put up on YouTube today
comes from a man named Stewart George
he's a handsome fella a weird fella
strange borderline serial killer kind of
fella anyway he's requested this let's
get to it over at our patreon page we do
weekly q and A's as well as TV show
reaction stream along for several shows
via them include reaction highlights and
John also does music video coverage
without the week so go ahead and check
us out over on our patreon page we'd
love to have you become a patron ejected
a patreon exists I love some of them at
our patreon page
[Music]
let's track this for the game Tony Stark
yeah boy genius American patriot I
remember watching this Leonard your
life's work in the hands of those
murders is that I would assume you are
is this the last act of defiance of the
great Tony stop discovering that hair
batteries or are you going to do
something
you know the sacrifice play to lay down
on a wire the other guy crawl over you
Jarvis he was told he was calculating he
never told me he loved me never even
told me he liked to digest me telling me
the whole future was riding for means
passing it now
I don't get mad [ __ ] Walt Disney
experience
whether ovaries kids win gods aliens of
a mannequin
[Music]
threat this that's you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the man who killed me matters
[Music]
go home
[Music]
I always trying to make us think Tony's
gonna die
always trying to make us think that
aren't you Marvel mortal one of these
days he's actually gonna die and you're
gonna be sad yep they're gonna be really
sad
I really do forget just how miserable it
must be to be Tony you know a lot of
times you hear celebrities or people
being compared to like oh he's like the
Tony Stark you know because you think of
like playboy billionaire cool cocky guy
which is like the upfront image that
Tony's always put on but underneath all
that he's a mess he's just always an
inner turmoil neurotic in just very on
the edge and a lot of guilt and blame
and just trying to figure out what his
purpose is and with a lot of sacrifice
and then making people upset that he
doesn't intend to make upset you know
don't want all the human beings endured
over time to I mean win I mean not only
did he lose his parents young but then
also finding out who's responsible and
all these things like there's some heavy
stuff that's come to him over the course
of the series and this was a nice
reminder to me of yeah when I think of
Tony Stark I just think of wisecracks
and I was like oh this is a really kind
of traumatized character right here yeah
just trying to make it all work with
this added burden and gift of all these
amazing inventions and whatnot yet the
man who had a resurgence of a career
through Ironman who's led the whole MCU
has never gotten even a say Oscar good
even a Golden Globe Award for playing
Ironman
and I think he freakin deserves it man
those ten minutes in spider-man
homecoming he was green-screen into this
scenes of Tom Holland we're some of the
best of that movie right there great
great screen you know for a guy who is
this smart this does show he makes a lot
of really bad decisions from times that
you should be the lead man you seem to
make a lot of really poor choices from
time to time here to those who
appreciate the difference between smart
and wise yeah Tony's got a lot of wisdom
to pick up over time for how smart he is
like with the Mandarin attacking his
home because he gave out his address
almost killed Pepper Potts because of
that he created Ultron he really helped
to create a divide amongst the Avengers
in civil war sokovia accords are because
of he's kind of like a hidden villain in
some ways there's an element to him that
her like that even though he was my
personal favorite character out of all
of infinity war was a fourteen-year-old
kid you gotta have a complex character
with their own fishermen downsides right
yeah and kudos to the top screen editor
here and to mosses to Tunis I know that
guy that's my cousin hey he used a lot
of footage of Ian's son who's kind of
different got in character me because he
died a little bit after he built his
first prototype Iron Man suit but he
wasn't used all of his footage it was
only a three and a half minute video but
a good chunk of it is dedicated to his
interaction with the insent and the
influence Unison played over him and
it's so true though and I feel like he's
never brought up again he's haven't
talked about I don't know if there's
like something about that actor that
really liked her or we just forgot about
him because he is such an integral part
too what made Tony Stark evolve into
Iron Man he was the guy who saved his
life
he was the guy who inspired him motivate
him to do something more he's the guy
helped him break out of the freakin cave
and he now this is one
and for what at least up until that
point was probably the most harsh and
and horrifying experience of his life
yet never brought up again never brought
oh that is a bit strange you'd think
that he would want to honor his Kevin
Feige you're racist I blame all this on
you even though Black Panther were just
won a few Oscars the Disney Store gonna
have a yinsen show on the Disney
streaming service that's survived he's
like Coulson he's not actually dead
yeah when they bring the snap back it's
gonna be good yeah you know I mean
reverse the snap yeah that'll be yeah
they'll reverse the snap and then
they'll bring back characters to just
died of other causes to second chances
and they do try to make you think Tony's
gonna die a lot there's a lot of shots
of it yeah I see my doom I feel like a
lot of these movies do that with a lot
of their heroes I feel like Iron Man
gets it a little bit more than everyone
else okay I can think of a lot more
moments you know why because I just
watched this video the nomination for
that phenomenon of course John well guys
he's gonna die in a vendor's end game I
can't wait for that to happen he better
die he's he better he better fly off
into the sunset Pepper Potts is gonna
not return anymore gonna toss versed if
they ever want me for something I'll
come back but you know she's not gonna
sign another committed contract deal and
I think that there's been so many teases
of him dying it feel like Toni kind of
wants to die yeah they're so SIG's Agee
with his character art lately he's up
here he's growing he gets rid of the
suits he's back in old trauma no
explanation about the suits then he's
lost pepper and he's all frickin
depressed and agitated in civil war than
he has pepper back at home cuz it's all
this like such weird back and forth of
where he's at in his life and I feel
like overall he's just a very depressed
guy and I think that it's about time he
dies he's gotta have a little bit of a
death wish I think that definitely isn't
fitting with his character yeah so let's
kill him off Marvel we all want it all
of us in space with no action scenes
except when he almost had an infinity
war
you can sit here and be cynical it's
time you know when they actually do
you're gonna of course before we wrap
this video up I would like to give a
shout out to the man who requested this
video his name is Stuart George Stuart
my friend if there's anyone who's like
Iron Man at our patreon page it's you
not because you're inventive not because
you're a superhero because you're
egotistical you're narcissistic you
don't work well with others and by the
third movie you start having these panic
attacks it's really weird you also don't
know how to be a good boyfriend you got
all the worst qualities of Tony Stark
but you're great at befriending kids
which isn't creepy at all hold for plain
Stewart I'm glad you have all the good
qualities of Tony Stark and I hope that
you can continue to utilize that to your
advantage
yeah freak guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
balichek Assam page around we got [ __ ]
yeah